race is not getting a lot of play but
alaska
has one congressional district and has
one politician
who is more famous than any other up
there that would be of course sarah
palin sarah palin
is running
for congress
and sarah palin is absolutely crushing
it
she won in the first round of voting for
alaska's congressional seat special
election
54.4 of the vote when that by the time
that had come in palin had 32 000 votes
to just over 20 000 for the second place
finisher uh she's she's doing right
she's absolutely crushing it the field
included 48 different candidates to
replace representative dun young who
died in march
and so now the top candidates will go on
they'll go to the next round of the
state's first ever ranked choice
non-partisan primary
so the the
parties don't really matter it's going
to be ranked choice it's going to be
kind of weird
it's weird in a different way but still
weird sort of like that that race down
in texas where the
prominent
republican woman
lots of momentum lots of energy where
she won as well
i was trying to think about what i feel
about sarah palin i don't know sarah
palin
sarah palin was the vice presidential
candidate
just around the time that i started to
really become involved in politics even
frankly a little bit before i was really
involved working on campaigns that sort
of thing
what do i think about sir i don't know
that much about sarah palin do you
follow alaska politics very closely
probably not
and yet
just deep in my gut
i like sarah palin
i was trying to figure out why do i like
sarah palin i don't really know that
much about her career
i don't haven't followed her very much
since she left
the presidential vice presidential
campaign trail i know she's done some
weird tv shows and things i haven't paid
attention to that so why do i like her i
like sarah palin
because they hate sarah palin
that's why that's what it comes down to
i don't know maybe sarah palin has some
problems but my gut tells me i am
inclined to like this woman because all
the right people hate her
and that's usually a pretty good rule of
thumb in politics right now
another prominent republican woman
lauren bobert is coming under fire i
think completely ridiculous spurious
attacks trying to oust her you know end
of the campaign surprise kinds of of
nonsense
i think why do i like lauren bober i
actually am friends with lauren bobert i
so i you know i've gotten to spend some
time with her personally i like her from
you know
what we've what we've uh how we've
interacted and the things that i
followed her do in congress but even if
i didn't even if i had never met lauren
bobert i didn't know anything about her
record i would still be inclined to like
lauren bobert why
because all the right people hate her
that's a good guide that is a good guide
to things because the people who hate
sarah palin and who hate lauren bobert
and who hate donald trump and who hate
ted cruz and who hate rhonda santas and
who hate all these guys
those people are wrong about pretty much
everything
do you think that
dr fauci likes sarah palin probably not
do you think joe bought well we know joe
biden do you think any of these people
and and politics is
in many ways a team sport
it has to be that's why we have parties
that's why we have elections that
because you can't it shouldn't just be a
team sport it has to it also has to have
something to do with reason and justice
and the truth and a role for
individuality breaking out of some stale
old talking points for goodness sakes
trump certainly did that in 2016. but
you need to come together as a team
and there's a reason there's a reason
why people who are pro-life
also
support economic growth
there's a reason why
people
who support american traditions and the
traditional american family also support
secure borders i know it seems like
those are different issues but they're
not they have a coherence they they
they say something about what we believe
about philosophy and theology and the
relation of man to the state there's
there's a kind of coherence to that okay
you actually
can
judge a man by his enemies
and right now this is a story we can't
get to i'll have to get to it tomorrow
gw george washington university has just
voted to get rid of its mascot who's a
guy who looks like george washington
called the colonial
the colon and they're voting to get rid
of that because they hate washington
they hate the colonials they hate amer
america's founding the people who hate
lauren bobert and sarah palin and donald
trump and all these people they also
hate george washington they want to tear
down his statues and christopher
columbus and
they
they are just they've got a bad view of
the world and so
especially in an election year i am very
inclined
to look at where my where my enemies and
my opponents are moving the people
they're afraid of the people they're
pushing back hardest against those are
the people that i'm going to defend
those are the people that i'm going to
stand
on the side with and hopefully win right
now go to altoira.com
michael insider intelligence estimates
that by the end of 2022 the number of us
adults who own at least one
cryptocurrency will climb 19 to 33.7
million
people some surveys show that as many as
85 percent of millennial millionaires
own crypto how about you do you own any
if you don't and you're not sure where
to start you should check out alto ira
alto offers alternative investment
opportunities such as private companies
crypto funds real estate venture capital
and more alto ira in particular is a
great way to start investing in trading
in crypto with a tax advantaged
retirement account no commissions no
paperwork no setup charges alto makes
investing in crypto so incredibly easy
even i can do it just create your
account transfer the funds start
investing done they're integrated with
coinbase you get secure trading 24 7 150
plus available coins on their interface
including bitcoin ethereum cordano
multiple ways to fund your account it
makes it super duper easy go to alto
crypto ira right now you can start your
account with as little as ten dollars
alto ira.com michael
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today that is alto
ira.com
michael
i'm so glad you like that clip now
you got to ring that bell subscribe get
the notifications right now stop
whatever you're doing stop
ring the bell subscribe now copy the
link in the url now
email it to your favorite friends and
you say you should watch this too and
subscribe greatly appreciate it we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you